bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france alors consignes bachelot a
été interpellée lors de la 46e cérémonie
des césar elle s'est également rendu au
théâtre de l'odéon occupée elle dit
comprendre votre inquiétude des paroles
on attend des actes ont répondu les
occupants du théâtre de quel acte parlez
vous aujourd'hui
écoutez il ya un certain nombre de
mesures qui doivent être reconduite
d'urgence notamment pour nos camarades
du spectacle enregistré puisque si nous
dans le spectacle du spectacle vivant
pardon parce que si nous dans le
spectacle peut enregistrer l'issue du
premier confinement l'activité a repris
globalement c'est beaucoup moins vrai du
spectacle du spectacle vivant
donc on avait obtenu l'année blanche
jusqu'au mois d'août 2021
on demande l'année blanche ce regard de
l'assurance chômage des intermittents du
spectacle on demande que cette mesure
soit reçoit reconduite
on demande que l'accès aux primo
entrants c'est à dire aux étudiants
d'écoles de spectacle enregistré soit
soient privilégiés on demande un plan de
soutien global à l'emploi et pas
simplement un plan de soutien aux
entreprises même s'il s'agit pas
d'opposer les les entreprises de la
culture et les salariés qui font la
culture mais qu il faut que l'aide aille
aussi à l'emploi on demande des moyens
pour garantir ensemble des droits
sociaux parce que dans la mesure où
notre secteur ne travaille pas et
notamment le spectacle vivant ça veut
dire moins de ressources pour les
caisses de retraite pour la formation
pour la médecine du travail pour les
congés payés puisque ont un système de
congés payés particulier donc voilà un
peu en étant aujourd'hui effectivement
des mesures en des mesures concrètes
ensuite il ya ce que vous avez évoqué un
instant dans votre journal savoir le
problème de la fermeture des salles de
cinéma qui accélère un processus de
déplacement des public de las
vers les plateformes numériques et on
voit bien puisque l'essentiel des
camarades chez nous qui travaillent pour
les pour les plateformes on beaucoup de
travail donc on va pas on va pas s'en
plaindre mais on craint effectivement à
l'horizon deux des 12 18 mois dix-huit
mois prochain que la mise en production
de films et déjà on observe auprès du
centre national de la cinématographie
que la mise en production des films à
venir se ralentissent alors avez vous
une visibilité sur les discussions en
cours c'est rien à écouter on nous dit
on va faire le nécessaire en sommes des
rapporteurs
le rapporteur qui a été nommé sur le
dossier assurance chômage on a tout lieu
de penser qui doit faire la
démonstration que peut-être enregistré à
mieux amener à mieux travaillé que le
spectacle vivant il va essayer de
diviser le monde du spectacle ce qu'on
ne souhaite pas parce que les
problématiques son sang sont les mêmes
pour tous
encore une fois même si on constate du
côté du spectacle pour enregistrer que
les choses vont moins mal que quelques
elles ne vont dans le spectacle vivant
on attend dans les prochaines semaines
voire les prochains mois une réduction
drastique des films de long métrage
notamment alors on a peut-être un
confinement strict un familièrement gens
me dire qui nous pend au nez
je pète visionnaire bien sûr mais le
gouvernement ne cesse de rappeler qu'il
est prêt à prendre des mesures
supplémentaires nous en tel contexte ne
comprenez vous pas ne serait-ce un petit
peu les règles sanitaires imposées dans
le milieu de la culture
écoutez c'est pas c'est pas ton qu'on ne
comprend pas les règles sanitaire opposé
dans le milieu de la culture on les
coupe on les comprend d'autant que nous
avons travaillé avec l'ensemble des
partenaires sociaux y compris les
représentants employeurs à des guides
dans le dans le cadre des comités
centraux d'hygiène et de sécurité à la
fois dans la production cinéma est à la
fois dans la production audiovisuelle à
des guides de préconisations sanitaires
pour que les gens puissent précisément
travailler
dans de bonnes conditions de sécurité et
force est de constater que ces
préconisations sont suivis et que il ya
très peu de contamination sur les lieux
de travail et notamment sur les lieux de
tournage
nous pensons qu'il y a moyen
effectivement de trouver et de mettre en
place un dispositif qui permettrait de
réouvrir un certain nombre de lieux
consacrés au spectacle laurent loi merci
d'avoir été en direct avec mon sur rt
france je rappelle que vous êtes délégué
général du syndicat des professionnels
de l'industrie de l'audiovisuel et du
cinéma remercier havre